my wife's working and I'm kind of doing
dad life you know I'm doing the
full-time full-time dad thing right now
which is amazing with the the pandemic
going around there's that anxiety about
working but I also just gained so much
time with my son
that is so valuable especially he's
almost three so it's just like this they
have had a couple months of just pure
time with him to watch them grow and to
teach him and and it's just been really
cool have you seen any of your movies or
no not yet he's come to visit me on set
one time which was kind of interesting
but yeah he doesn't he doesn't really
get the concept yet so maybe one day
he'll think it's cool but then I do this
but at this point um yeah it just
doesn't really register if he ever gets
into superheroes they're gonna press
them to have like a favorite x-man like
that oh this is Bobby Amy's wife call me
Iceman
I think it's crazy to think about x-men
having happened like 20 years ago you
kick started everything kick started
everything people do say that like well
x-men started at all and that's like
well yeah but Batman was out first it
wasn't a Marvel film um Sue's DC but I
was like that's my first memory of like
a high quality superhero film was like
the Tim Burton Michael Keaton Batman
like that to me was someone I remember
first but it was several years and other
films like that weren't being made and
then it feels like what next one came
out then the ball started to roll with
all the talk of uh of excellent coming
into the MCU how much do you think about
or want to revisit your character within
this new sort of sandbox in this new
play back yeah I mean look playing that
character for all those years it changed
my life and it changed my career so I
would always love to play that character
again but will we get a chance to do
that I have no idea well for now fans
can catch Shawn in the new crime
thriller darkness falls they call you
the suicide guy job you've got to get
back in the saddle Elizabeth took her
own life
available on-demand the movie has Shawn
playing detective Jeff Anderson a man
convinced his wife's death was actually
part of a larger string of serial
killings this is dark yes like this is a
heavy heavy with the director Julian
Terry when we talked about the script he
was like you know people will probably
see this as a vengeance film and a
revenge film but he's like I really see
it about as a film about fathers and
sons between our serial killer and his
son and Jeff and his son